kim kardashian and pete davidson do date
night with kim's sister chloe why not
it's such a beautiful thing on wednesday
night kim pete chloe and friends hit up
quarters korean barbecue in la followed
by some fun at 60 out escape room where
they had the whole place to themselves
the 41 year old kkw beauty founder
rocked an all-black ensemble complete
with a hoodie leggings and a pair of
thigh high satin boots while the 28 year
old saturday night live star kept it
casual in a hat black hoodie jeans and
sneakers i love that and guys check out
the love birds walking together doing
some serious hand holding i'm just
rolling with it as for chloe seems she
got the black on black memo from kim
looking fierce in a beanie bomber jacket
balenciaga leggings and nike sneakers
an eyewitness tells et that the group
was super low-key at dinner and stayed
pretty under the radar it's a different
experience for sure
adding that everyone seemed super
relaxed and happy i love that that
energy in my life quote pete and kim
look so genuinely happy together they
looked as though they are really digging
each other and having such a blast it's
always so much fun
the eyewitness adds that they were
smiling and giggling with each other
that was really funny and kim's body
language towards pete was giving off
major romance energy yes
the duo's latest date night comes just
two weeks after they were spotted
grabbing pizza and ice cream in la
and earlier this month the pair jetted
off to the bahamas together
with a source telling e.t at the time
that they wanted some time away before
the year ramps up at the end of the day
life is about being happy still neither
kim nor pete have publicly confirmed
their relationship and their friends and
family they're staying pretty
tight-lipped too
you just gotta roll with it
on new year's eve kim's mom kris jenner
sidestepped andy cohen's questions with
an assist from kylie jenner's daughter
stormy webster you know everyone is
talking about kim's new relationship
with pete davidson if you had the chance
to spend time with them how are they as
a couple hey stormy oh
um you sit right here um yeah
nice distraction good timing stormy
perfect
right
and pete's close pals are following suit
i don't really stay up to date with what
my good friend uh pete's up to as long
as he's having fun and he's happy that's
all i care about he's a love gotta ask
you your boy pete davidson and kim
kardashian how happy are you for him
and while no one's officially commenting
on kim and pete's love this public
handholding says it all
[Music]
you